hi guys I'm Michael FINA and I'm here to
answer 30 questions in 3 minutes
[Music]
Halle Wong's left breast a great book a
little Britta Sri Racha dreams by
Fleetwood Mac there's one where Celine
Dion when you love I don't remember but
she's walking through the hallways and
it's in the middle of the night
Showtime fun frolicking for fur what's
your sign and is it one that is
compatible with my overcooked to me and
Jack would would would have a great time
well so many Rocco from Rocko's Modern
Life Air Bud and Sam to Cannes because
he has range I love in and out and I'm
from New York and it was mind-blowing
when I had the animal style burn I like
a good room temp I like a dirty chai a
latte with a shot of espresso and then
he kept - it's called a filthy chai
dangerous territory every day every
memory with Rihanna she is incredible I
like all the cat the cat instagrams cats
there was this one cat and she was
reacting to a filter a cat filter that
his owner owner had and she was like
what I like drama DS or Core commas if I
said 12 would that be embarrassing
because it's true I love the green one
that is named after a nut
pistachio Backstreet Boys dude like
growing up Kevin Brian Nick and AJ just
named them it's the ambulance or the
girl did does this not breakfast cuz who
eats but I don't got time Ali my
breakfast at like 2:00 or 4:00 p.m. and
the first meal of the day not the last
one though I hate to say it but but
probably probably Instagram it's
actually Taylor from the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills and she's screaming and
then the other side is a cat it'll show
a license plate and it's spelled a new
start a and you sta RT and Taylor is
like a new start and the cats like anus
tart I'm not one of those Psychopaths
that leave dark mode on during the
daytime I have it where it comes
naturally on when it's dark because I'm
not weird Judge Judy the last person I
faced time we probably my grandma I get
back on let me tell you something
Scorpios don't need them a laugh or cry
or a combination of both and then use
the bathroom probably figuring out how
to use the chromecast yeah I love the
housewives
I love the housewives and lastly Alyssa
but actually boys he lucked out Holly I
don't Jesus I'm so sorry Howie you
impact my life and continue to inspire
me every day oh my god
I feel bad for an owie yeah how he's
great
[Music]
[Applause]